wang hao will have seven minutes
and there is no increment until mu 40
and wang hao will have draw odds and
they are off
what are we seeing are we going to see a
ross alimo
yeah
this she is saying okay this is a
must-win situation
no more assaults vesnikov
let's check out
the rosso limo which
is also what he switched to in his world
championship match against gelfant where
they started debating the sesnikov
but then vichy
later scored a key victory in the rosso
limo this is a theoretical line has been
played between
karana and carlson among others very
complex stuff pawn to b5
the white bishop goes to
d6
but van gaal does not want to allow that
goes pawn to d6 i if memory serves i
thought bishop a4 was the move here
but vishy probably has something in mind
because bishop c4
allowing this d6 move because i thought
if you go here
now d6 doesn't work because knight takes
did he mix up the move or he's taking
some time yeah it might be too maybe
something went wrong or
just
knows a lot about it one of the two i
think he knows a lot about it because
it's still very much in main line
i think he's messed it up ah okay might
have six i think that's just just better
already
was a little
slip of the hand because you have to go
bishop a4
then the line is b5 bishop b3
and here if d6 a4 puts pressure but if
you start with bishop c4 since
the pin is no longer there now black can
just go d6 as van gaal did
and he's comfortable might be two
knight of six
and
black's better
h6 what is that about
he wants to stop knight g5 but why just
move move the knight out
knight g5 castles
what is he worried about
i don't know that's weird h6
why exactly
well it does seem like a interesting
move at least maybe he just wants to get
out of
i don't know
maybe wank how also doesn't isn't so
familiar with the line but uh it's all
about being familiar developed a piece
instead of moving moving a flank pawn
this is shocking now anna uses the time
to go bishop d5
and after knight e7 there is knight to
c4
is that sold
i don't know if it's a big deal but at
least uh he gets to target something
before black is developed
yeah
i think 97 has to be played though
and um
you have to meet
castles
the pawn has gone
she takes
quite very much back in business
he could drop back with the bishop and
then if takes takes
the queen takes there's
what i think they call a night fork
there is a night fork on the board um
i think this is this bishop move is
probably a really good move because
otherwise black starts the kickback
but uh after night after the bishop
retreats
can you just
i was thinking bishop
we should be six or something try to
yeah doesn't look so pleasant
or maybe knight takes bishop and then
just
yeah but the knight can come to d
d6 on all these variations so
sometimes
swings and roundabouts
knight comes to d6 and that's it okay
bishop g3 on the board
and
okay
knight takes bishop is the most forcing
move
pawn takes
you cannot capture the pawn because of
knight v6
as kindly pointed out by jan
looks unpleasant the knight has to drop
back and hope for the best van gaal goes
rook of 80s really
trying to break all the rules today
h6 okay truck of eight
yeah well he's anticipating knight to d6
but alan doesn't have to do it can just
play any move h3 or whatever
and this is still not a threat because
of
the aforementioned
fork can he
make an improving move
yeah rocky one rock c one h3
any no smoke yeah
h3 on the board
and what about now should black try try
the kick back
what's this
push the knight away b5
isn't it a
kick forward
yeah
i have kicked the ball forward okay
well
i don't know
it doesn't look like a great position
maybe bishop and then just simply might
be
live with this
56 knight f5 maybe h3 has some
some drawbacks as well in that
bishop is no longer covered
okay he's taken it off
and uh knight e7 on the board
there goes that knight
now maybe you can go bishop d6
yeah
completing that little
dance should d6 rook e8 bishop d6 maybe
b5
yeah yeah okay
no i'm starting to think this h3 was
maybe not the most useful
i would be nice if the rook was on e1
yeah exactly having a rock somewhere
feels much more helpful man
other moves could be
there should be five
but then again that just feels like
maybe it's not enough to
play for it's very logical just yeah
maybe black isn't time to
to simplify i'm not sure if queen d5
works
i guess so and if the other knight takes
then 25 certainly works and it's
probably too dry
i know because knight takes d4 but that
also doesn't feel like putting too much
pressure
yeah after knight takes d5 this might be
three
keeps the game going he does like his
knights
yeah
he does
and
there is some uncomfortable
pressure
one thing they kind of immediately pops
out is that the black knight can't
actually move because of knight b6 ideas
after the queen gets traded off
so
yeah that would be unfortunate
i spot all those cheap
tricks nice
but uh
presumably so taking some time here b5
on the board
and talking about time bang how only has
uh
two
coming up to two and a half minutes
and we are move 19.
so whilst his position does look like
it's okay it's holdable
he doesn't have much time on the clock
and he will not be getting any increment
no there's still a lot of play in the
position it's not like the game will be
over anytime soon queen
going somewhere t1 rookie one
and it looks like the carlson game is
over magnus looks upset what happened
there oh
he did win apparently why is he so upset
was it on time because rajabov had
almost no time on the clock it's also
dad lost the final position
okay yeah missed something
come on
not upset then
maybe that's his happy face
okay the world champion wins his first
classical game
picking up three points very important
and
knight c5
nightmare time
wang
so this means um
wang hao now coming close to two minutes
on the clock i mean he has to develop
the light square bishop so
rook moves up okay
the rook is dominated
yeah no didn't have a great square so he
moved the rock and b3
offering the exchange sacrifice
yeah putting the david howell pawn
to dominate the knight on b6 nice move
and uh my d7 but doesn't solve
nothing
is the stupid night gets exchanged
still some pressure
well the knight can simply retreat right
hasty
knight to d
i will be tempted to get knuckle knight
to e4
and uh one cow is very insistent he
wants to trade tonight
which makes a lot of sense because now
his bishop also has a square to go
particularly
ricci one is a very nice move with the
threat hang on can he do that
he planned a rock state
yeah
well now shaking his head
how does this go queen is seven
pin yeah okay
right
maybe just pin directly
i thought rook takes work and after
bishop takes work knight c8
ah
okay does this continue queen c5
okay let's see
see what happens when how it didn't even
bother he gave up his queen between c8
knight c8 roxy 8 queen g4
so he has a rook and
a minor piece
for the queen not quite enough
some drawing chances but combined with
the clock situation
it's a sad sad situation
well the good news is that he has a few
minor pieces so if needs be he can just
waste a few
that's a good point and get to that
golden move 40
get that one second increment
very generous time control
up do one play
so tricky
these pieces they are not
too well coordinated
coming to a minute
securing the c3 square very good
it's on a dark square though the lights
and white has a dark square bishop
look d
look d7 some squares for his queen it's
queen
we need to move the queen out of the way
right
thick of it
queen has to go to
f3
f4
d3
how very focused in that queenside
situation
almond has found a good square foot yeah
and uh
nice strategy from anand perhaps uh
going to trade off a set of rooks looks
like his hand wanted to play rook d8
then he reconsidered
there you go and once what the hand
wants
f6 it's still
still tough to break through
queen takes queen d7
okay
probably the queen will manage to
yeah chase
d8 queen c6
too many weaknesses
nice move allows the white king to hide
on h2 without worrying about checks
e5
that is a nasty trick
prepared with 40 seconds on the board
bishop e5
he's been around he's gonna
make some luft g3
g4
982 hang on and this allows some some
trick yeah queen c6
uh
ron how is shaking his head now the
bishop is loose bishop h6 check is
possible
is there anything better
queen c2 is also there
bishop h6 is the most forcing points two
and rc3
h6 does look good because the black king
ends up being so weak as well yeah and
the the rook and knight are not the best
pieces to coordinate together with
bishop h6
and then just under two minutes and they
have now reached mu 40 which means that
they will be getting that one second
increment
knight to c3 he's probably checkmate
somehow
f4 threatening queen h8 forcing king h7
eventually
we'll do some checks but the king can
walk to h4
ph3
taking a moment checking for night forks
but he won't let go
and that's it it's over
and vishy collects
one and a half points
another victory for the indian grand
master incredible performance
yeah
great
i i
once again you know he's showing
what a player he is you know he can play
blitz